عدنا ومجددا الى بحر الصين ولكن من وجهي
الصراع والتنافس الى وجه اخر يضم الصين مع
روسيا في تحالفا رسائله لا تتوقف ونواره
بحريه وجويه هي نمطيات تجري بشكل تجرى
بشكل بشكل سنويا منذ عام 2012 لكنها تاتي
هذا العام تطوير خط قوه سيبيريا واحد
وتشيني بنائه غاز جديد سيبيريا اثنين بين
الشريكين الشرقيين وصلته السياسه كم
الطاقه الروسيه تتجه شرقا ومع دخول الخط
الجديد للخدمه في 2030 فان مجموع ما ستضخه
روسيا من غاز للصين عبر الخطين عبر النقل
البحري سيبلغ نحو اربعه سنوات
مليار متر مكعب ما شكل كره 61 فيلم 100 من
حجم صادرات الغاز الروسيه لاوروبا
تحولون اقتصاديا ضخم بين ان البعد
الاستراتيجيه تفوق هنا لنقل الثقل
الاقتصادي الروسي نحو الشرق وقبل القفزات
كان هناك خطوات فيمنذ عام 2008 ارتفعت
المبادلات التجاريه تدريجيا بين الصين
وروسيا من 56
مليار دولار الى 111 مليار في العام في
العام الواحد وفيما يهدف بوتن الى بلوغها
الى 200 مليار دولار في العام 2025
وجوه التعاون كثيره ويكفي ان الرئيس
عام 2013 مع الوقت ومع زيارات نمت
العلاقات ونقصد الصداقه
[موسيقى]
تليفون